hey there football fans you love
Mattel's football 1 then you're gonna
love Mattel's football 2 even more it's
all the exciting gameplay of the
original with even more realistic true
to life movements now you can run
forward and backward and they've
extended the playing field to 10 yards
dive into the 9 by 3 LED screen you'll
feel like you're really in the stadium
he's going for it going for it touchdown
here's the kicker you've all been
waiting for with football - you can now
pass the ball for the very first time
play by yourself or with a friend with
the simulated realistic game sounds like
the refs whistle in the victory - you
can not only see but hear the excitement
and with the handy mute switch you can
keep playing all night long without
waking your little brother
if football is in your sport of choice
Mattel's also created basketball in
baseball so everybody wins
let us know what retro gadgets you've
got in the back of your closet in the
comments and please subscribe to the
wired champ